we weirdly like I grew up when I was
real young my dad had like a hundred
million dollars he was huge wait wait
wait wait wait when you were young your
dad had a hundred money I was like three
my dad was worth like 100 million is
this before the big crash yeah yeah so
he he I think he's still like one of the
top five
um biggest largest IPO openings on Wall
Street ever
um he was like in the.com boom like it
was a company called log on America by
the time I was six he was worth
absolutely nothing
how do you lose everything
I I'm not 100 sure like because it's
still I've never really had you know
that in-depth conversation about it from
what my understanding is the company's
stock was going down he was 28 30 or
something like that so he's that the
company stock was going down and I think
he was using his own money to buy more
stock in the company to keep it up which
is legal but it's not smart because
you're buying your own business that's
tax right right so yeah so I never we
had like a uh you know we had things
like we lived in this big house but by
the time I was six the lights were
getting shut off there was no like the
cars were getting repossessed like we
were dead broke we couldn't even eat
dinner so how old are you I was so six
to twelve we were pretty destitute
really yeah and then when I was 14 to 18
in high school he had money again he's
like an entrepreneur so he'll have a
business and it'll be going well he
became a millionaire again not a
millionaire but we were comfortable
where where I was like you know we had
Vehicles like he was able to get me a
car like stuff like that so I'm super
super grateful by the way I uh from the
way I grew up because I experienced
absolute poverty and I experienced you
know uh you know going so you're humble
you were humbled as were your parents
are so so so grateful that that's what
happened because if my dad had a hundred
million dollars when I was in high
school I I wouldn't be you'd be a wreck
I'd be a [ __ ] Knight were you a
nightmare in high school were you kind
of like a partier or a party animal so I
you played hockey yes yes so so
basically what happened was when I was
12 was my 12 and 13 were my rebellious
years I got cut from this hockey team
because so I was I went to Long Island
to play I would drive up every weekend
to play for this team called the Long
Island gulls we were like third ranked
in the entire world are you serious yeah
and you were that good dude my so my
summer team when I was 12 was Conor
McDavid Daniel strong
um you know you played with these guys
yeah oh insane like Samuel Blair like
were you one of the good players yeah
always top four top four defenseman on
this team
um I've literally I think I played with
almost one person on every NHL team
right now
um what yeah so that was that was
anybody on the Rangers
hey guys I'm Tom Welling I used to play
Clark Kent on Smallville I'm Michael
Rosenbaum I used to play Lex Luthor on
Smallville join us every week as we go
back way back I'm excited I know are you
can't wait join Tom Welling and Michael
Rosenbaum every week as they rewind
every episode of Smallville and discuss
their experiences with friends fans and
co-stars talkville the ultimate
Smallville podcast
foreign